president
party secretary the people's leader and
to some
just papa she xi jinping is called many
things and as the communist party
celebrates its 100 year anniversary
the 68 year old is consolidating his
position as the country's most
powerful leader in decades the party has
united and it led the people
in opening a great path making great
achievements
forging a great spirit she has led china
for nine years
and after abolishing presidential term
limits in 2018
is unlikely to step down anytime soon he
began his term with an anti-corruption
campaign
which saw one and a half million
officials punished it also
purged the party of any opposition to
his rule
she then promised to end extreme poverty
nationwide
a promise he said he fulfilled last year
many say
these feats have given rise to a status
on par with the party founder mao zedong
the chinese people have advanced very
well and they don't want to give that up
and they won't and they they'll they'll
attach themselves to any leader
who is able to you know not only promise
but deliver
the son of revolutionary elites she was
sent to rural northeastern china during
the cultural revolution
where he joined the party and rose
through the ranks
china has since transformed into the
second largest economy in the world
with technological prowess second only
to the us
and growing global influence his
admirers say she is the ideal person
to bring china into the modern era
critics say
he is a dictator so that's like a
natural curse
for any dictatorship however it may be
mighty
maybe effective maybe charismatic at the
beginning
over time a dictatorship will decay
simply because
you know it does not have the kind of a
diversity
kind of sensible debate over policies
under his watch
authorities have cracked down on descent
in hong kong and xinyong
and according to human rights groups
imprisoned up to one million uighurs in
re-education camps
for she the battle to maintain power
isn't just political
it's ideological for now in china
only one path leads to the greatest
rewards
the path of loyalty to the leader
so certainly there was a really great
extravagant spectacle held this morning
on thursday here in beijing in tiananmen
square 70 000 people gathering
uh with precision like performance
really sending this official message
to not only the chinese people but to
the world so there's two ways to read
this one is to take it at face value
that
the party has made china stronger than
ever before
and that it will continue to succeed and
it's proven
that this system which it refers to as
socialism with chinese characteristics
has worked for china and it will work
for the rest of the world another way to
read this
is that this is just the surface and
potentially underneath
really the communist party is extremely
insecure that
it is extremely insecure that at any
point it could lose grip on
an increasingly educated creative
and informed group of 1.4 billion
people and it needs huge ideological
propaganda events like this
in order to help retain their loyalty
which it could lose
at any time